The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All
right, so we're back.
We're going to do the
examples we just described
in the previous notes.
And again, once again,
these are in the--
if you have your
d4m directory here,
they're in Examples,
Applications, BioBlast.
This shows you the two
programs we're going to run.
We just have two examples.
And then we're going
to be comparing
two pieces of actual data.
So if you look at
this, this shows you
what that data looks like.
So sequence ID, and then
very long sequences here.
It'd be sure nice if they
were all the same length,
but they certainly
are not the same time.
They vary dramatically
here you can see.
Look at that guy.
What's he doing?
Super long.
So this is a reference
bacteria dataset.
This is known data.
And this is a sequence
here of some data
taken from somebody's palm.
This is open source
data, so this is just
an example of that.
And so you can
imagine one would want
to do a comparison of
the data, of what the DNA
sequences of bacteria
on the person's hand
are with some reference dataset.
So obviously, we're not
going to be using a dataset.
This is a very
small dataset here.
We wouldn't expect to
have any matches here
and we're not going to
have any, but this just
shows you how that works.
So let me go over here,
and so the first one here
was this BB1.
All right, so what we've
done is we set our word size.
We're going to
use 10 base pairs,
so that's where we're
basically dealing with 10-mers.
And wrote a little
program here that what
it does is given a CSV file,
FASTA file, and a word size,
it then creates the associative
array as we described.
So basically each
sequence will be a row.
So we'll get into that.
And likewise, each 10-mer
will then be a column.
And so we do this
for the two datasets.
Here is our matrix multiply,
so A1 times A2 transpose
gives us A1, A2.
And here's is our pedigreed
matrix multiply, the CatKeyMul
A1, A2 transpose, and
gives us A1, A2 key.
And so we can now look at that.
So A1 has 198-- that's the
bacteria-- 198 sequences
with 8,001 unique 10-mers.
A2 had 1,000 sequences
with 2,365 unique 10-mers.
And then when you
matrix multiply them,
you see that 85 of the
195 in the reference
had a match with 415 of
the 999 in the sample.
So we're losing about
half in each case
because the associative rate
does not store empty values.
There's going to be no key
which is a completely empty row
or a completely column.
So we can now look at that data.
So if we look at Figure 1 here.
So this is A1, so this
shows you-- again, here,
why don't we zoom in?
So that gives you better
sense of the structure.
You can actually click on that.
So here's a 10-mer that appears
in an awful lot of things.
So basically this 10-mer appears
And these are examples
of a row corresponding
to a particular sequence ID.
So that's A1.
That's the reference.
A2, the sample, pretty much
the same type of thing.
Although a little bit
different structure--
more these dense things, maybe.
Why don't we zoom in on
one of these blobs here?
See those type of blobs there.
We've got this guy.
Who's he?
This guy begins with GCCAC and
GCCTT and other types of things
there.
And this is the cross, so
if we go now to Figure 3,
this is the cross
correlation of all those,
and it holds the count.
So you can see here 1, 1--
most of these are just 1.
1-- and unless I did some
kind of thresholding,
I probably couldn't even find
the ones that were larger.
And then figure 4 here is
our pedigreed multiplication,
so now it shows you
what the actual.
So this tells us that
this reference sequence
ID and this sample sequence
ID had a match at this 10-mer.
So we back here.
And as we see, as
I clicked on that,
it printed out
the full sequence.
So if you wanted to ever
just do a cut and paste
and then put this in
something else-- so, like,
if I wanted to look at this
row, I could then do A1,
and that gives me that row.
And I can do other things.
I could do sum that-- I
could sum the columns up.
That tells me there's 138 unique
sequences in that sequence ID.
So those types of things there.
All right.
I think we pretty
much covered that.
And so now we'll go on
to the next example.
And I apologize, this
takes a little bit longer
to run because now I'm doing two
things when I read in the data.
I'm doing the same
thing I did before
in terms of [INAUDIBLE]
I want 10-mers,
then I'm going to
read the data again
at a slightly
different function,
and it's going to return
two associative arrays.
This associative array
was the same as before,
which showed us the actual
counts-- how many times.
The next one gives us
a concatenated list
of the positions, so if
it appears five times,
it'll actually show us--
it'll hold that information--
a list of the five locations
in the greater sequence, which
then allows us to do those
things I talked about before.
So this takes a
minute to do that.
Probably with some
optimization, I have no doubt
that this could be made faster.
And also with the video
recording going on,
we have a lot of pressure
on this personal computer.
Just some additional
information here
in terms of the whose
command, so we basically
did whose A to show me all the
different associative arrays
I have, as you can see.
And this tallies up the
bytes that are associated.
So our first associative
array, as you saw,
was about 700 kilobytes.
And that basically adds
up all the data stored
and all the data
structures inside it.
Usually does a pretty good
job of that, likewise.
And you can see, there's
a significant reduction
in the total size of that.
And in this case,
we didn't really
add that much by
adding the keys,
so this is a very nice dataset
for us to do our CatKeyMul on.
There was no dense
diagonal or anything
like that to get
in our way there,
so that was a very
useful thing to have.
At least we're now onto the
second read, so almost there.
And being able to click on the
thing it actually printed out
is because when we actually
do the spy plot, in this case,
it works out pretty well because
our keys are relatively short,
but we do truncate that.
So if you have a row key or a
column key that's very long,
when we do the plots
we truncate that,
and then you would
never actually know
what the true full string was.
I think we're just
about finished there.
All right, so again,
we read in the data,
and now I wanted
to make a degree
distribution of the data.
So just like we did our
degree distributions earlier,
there's a great
way to get a sense
of the overall statistics.
So I took one,
A1N, and the way I
do that is I have the
associative array, A1.
If I do the ADJ or
adjacency matrix,
this basically just pops
out the internal sparse
matrix that's stored.
And now I can do
regular math on that.
And we happen to have this
little built-in function called
out degree, which
essentially does, on the out
direction, the appropriate
sums and returns
a sparse matrix which we can
then plot in this log log form.
So is the reference data.
You see as this
distribution here,
which is very power
law-like, although, as we
saw in the earlier classes,
unless we properly fit and bin
this, we wouldn't really
know if this was a power law
or something like it.
But probably our first order
linear fit of a power law
would be at least a
good place to start,
as it usually is with this data.
There's the other one.
Would appear to be even
more power law-like,
but again, until we bin it, we
don't really know what happens.
When we start binning
this stuff up here,
maybe it will bow up in
some way, maybe it won't.
Probably it would.
Probably it would
look more like this.
A question for you,
or a good question
is I showed you
that other dataset,
and it didn't look like this.
You saw a very almost log
normal Gaussian distribution.
It's the same data.
It's still 10-mer type of data,
and so the only difference
is the size.
And so when you have
10-mers, since you
have four choices of
letter, you essentially
have 2 million total
possible 10-mers.
So this data set-- in fact,
we can count here, right?
That's A1.
If we do N and Z-- we
only have 274,000 entries,
so we're not fully sampling the
2 million possibilities here.
In the other dataset,
that database
was actually 500
million entries.
And so we're really
fully sampling,
and so basically
what's happening
is these guys are rare,
they don't show up,
and you're hitting them
once, and eventually
you begin to create this sort
of more Gaussian distribution
look, or bell curve look when
you start fully sampling.
I don't know if that's
generally true or not,
but one could hypothesize that a
lot of the data-- and this just
a guess-- a lot of the data we
see is power law because we're
not fully sampling the
total space that emerges,
or that total space is growing
at a rate as we sample it.
So domain names--
we haven't fully
sampled the entire space of
domain names, and the name,
and the set of domain
names, and the unit
continues to grow at a
fairly significant rate.
Now, maybe one day there will
stop being the new domain
names, and then when we
start doing our sampling,
maybe our distributions
and domain names
won't look so power
law anymore, but more
like a log normal distribution
with a kind of bell shape.
Just a hypothesis, but
certainly many data
we have don't do that.
Now, of course, the
easiest way for me
to change this is
instead of doing 10-mers
would be to do 20-mers.
Now I've dramatically increased
the space of possibilities,
and so the odds of
having just statistical
matches start piling
up are very, very low.
So that is certainly
something that people do, too.
And in the case for the
calculation we were doing,
we just got lucky.
We actually did not think 10-mer
would be the right sampling
for that data.
We thought it would
be a higher number
like a 15-mer or
a 20-mer, and it
turns out the 10-mer was just
actually spot on in terms
of giving us this nice
balance between sampling,
but statistical power
that we could eliminate
more common occurrences.
All right, so we plotted
the out degree again,
a very useful technique.
One should always understand
the overall statistics
of one's data.
We're doing the same
cross correlation
here that we did before, except
since in that previous dataset
the value didn't store
to the count-- that
was a very fast read, and
all the values were 1-- here
we actually have a count.
And so in this
particular correlation,
we don't care if well, this
10-mer appeared 10 times
in this one sequence
and appeared 3 times
in this other sequence,
and when we multiply them
together we get a 30.
We're really more interested
in, like, how many
unique 1's did they each have?
How many distinct
1's did we each have?
So we use the
double logi function
to basically convert
all our numbers back
to just 0's and 1's, and then
do that correlation again.
And since the
values don't matter
when we do the CatKeyMul,
we don't need to do that,
and then we do the
same correlation.
And so here we are.
We're finding the sequences
that have a greater than 8
match here.
Actually doing some fairly
inside tricks here to do that.
You might ask, what is this put?
So it's fairly clear
what I'm doing here.
I'm taking this count
and I'm saying, please
return the sub-associative
array of all things with greater
than a value of 8, or
more than eight matches.
All right, that's good.
Then I'm flooring that and
saying, make that all just 1's.
And then I'm doing this trick
here, which is called PutVal,
and I'm giving it
this random string.
So right now this is
just an associative array
without a value.
When I put that thing in
there, since all my things have
a value of 1 and I'll have
one string, it's now saying,
you know what, I've just
made all those values tilde.
I'm like, why on earth
would we do that?
Well, it's because when
I AND them together,
we have to decide what
mathematically-- when
we AND two associative
arrays together,
if you recall the lecture where
we talk about these collision
functions, we have to pick a
collision function for the two
strings.
And this key stores
this pedigreed list,
which I really want to keep.
And this just shows me which
ones are the high match,
and I don't really
care about that.
Well, the default collision
function, when in doubt,
throughout d4m is min.
So tilde is lexicographically
after every other printable
character in the alphabet.
So when I do a
min here, I'm just
going to always return
these values here.
So there was only one
entry greater than 8,
and I ANDed them together.
It then did a min of tilde
with this whole string here,
and it said, aha, C
is less than tilde.
I'm just going to give you
the C, and so there we go on.
So this is just a
cute trick, but it's
a way of using the collision
function in the group theory
that we talked about in earlier
lectures to get a very nice
just selecting the
one that I want here.
And so that's what that does.
And then there you can
see of this sequence
ID and this sequence ID, they
had greater than eight matches,
and this was the exact
10-mers that actually matched.
And then we can go back
before and look up those two
sequences, compare them side
by side in the original data,
and then we see these were
the actual positions here.
And you would probably
look at these-- well,
what do we think here?
Well, 137 and 138,
that's 139, 140,
141, and then jumping
all the way to 149.
So looks like those guys are
all part of one long group.
But then 60 and 172 and 130
are probably isolated 10-mers.
And then over here
what do we have?
We have 111-- no, but we do
have 119, 120, 121, 122, 123,
so that's probably also
a bigger group match.
In fact, those all line up with
this, except for the 149 year.
Well, actually, no.
Some of them match,
some of the time.
So they're each part
of a larger piece,
but they aren't contiguous
with each other.
And that's the kind of thing
that people who do this
then really look at.
And, of course, a real match
would be more like something
with many more sequences.
This is all just
random randomness
and things like that.
All right, so that's the demo.
I want to thank you.
And again, next week tell your
friends who weren't here today
that that is the one lecture.
If you had to come to one
lecture in this entire class--
I didn't tell you that at
the beginning, you notice,
because then you would have
skipped the other seven.
But no, what we've
done before will really
make that a lot easier.
That's the real one, and
you will then be able to go,
when you leave that lecture,
run all those examples
on those test databases
that we have there
from your LO grid accounts,
and have all that kind of fun.
And we really want to do that
because we've released d4m
on the web, we need
people to test it.
It's much better if you
guys find the issues,
and then we'll just
make it better.
And likewise, it's a step
towards you guys actually
using the technology for
your actual application.
So thank you very much.